are you Dan Goodrich could be with you
Mike holiday yeah happy holidays and
Merry Christmas to you too
so are have you been like the rest of us
in the national media sometimes
forgetting that they're no longer the
San Diego Chargers and still calling
them at catch yourself I do that one I'm
very proud that I have not called them
San Diego once really sad well yeah I
haven't called Los Angeles either is
funny that is Paris to me you know it
always be my standing there charges
there's somebody else's now mmm-hmm so
let's what do you think of those
scenarios that I just positive which one
you think is the most realistic to
prevent the Patriots from hosting an AFC
championship game losing the Buffalo
this weekend or two either Kansas City
or Baltimore in the divisional weekend
yeah I think yeah you know you talk
about history that's important no
question but it's Baltimore and harv are
there
Kansas City looks like they're back to
when they were five ago and looking like
the best team in the league and it was a
long time ago when they you know they
spanked the Patriots but they did spank
them so they do have a plan that will
work you know so either of those two I
guess I'll head there I'm not sure about
Buffalo beating them though this weekend
well you know that one would be the
obviously the most far-fetched one and
it should Buffalo lose this one it's
entirely possible that the Chargers
would be able to make the playoffs since
they've already gotten a head-to-head
win against the team that decided for
one week to try Nathan Peterman that
might be something that they'll be
regretting all offseason long what do
you think about the Chargers chances to
make the playoffs and make a run after
seeing what they looked like against
Kansas City however in week 15 Dan that
was a problem I expected this would be a
very competitive game this weekend with
the Jets just because the Jets seem to
have settled down and Todd Bowles seems
to be in place for the near future so I
think all that talk will help the team
and they played pretty well against New
Orleans last week running the ball
especially and that has been a weakness
for the Chargers
year is stopping the run so again it's
one of those games where the team that
scores early and establishes control
gets that momentum that good vibe going
usually at the end of the season they
win that ballgame so the I think that's
the important thing to keep your eye on
not only in this game but in a lot of
games this weekend which is the best
team you've personally laid eyeballs on
this year Dan because you also call
games on Westwood one radio you've seen
a ton of teams in front of you which is
the best team well it's hard to go
against New England we've seen them a
number of times and you know Tom Brady I
think is having just a fabulous year at
at one point I thought it was perhaps
his best year but you know after what
happened last week you can see you know
he is 40 years old and against any
strong pass rush it's going to bother
any quarterback and he kind of proved
he's he's human last weekend but their
resiliency their ability to win games
coming from behind all the things that
have made them champion so many times
they're all still there well I mean and
that's why I think a lot of people are
looking at what's going on this week
with his trainer that Bill Belichick
kicked the trainer out for the exception
of him only training Tom on the facility
and everyone else has got to see him
elsewhere that we're trying to see if
this is something behind the scenes that
could be something that manifests itself
on the field Dan I mean did you ever
have a situation when you were playing
but you saw teammates or yourself had
something going on that Coryell or
somebody ought to step in and and and
change things up midseason no we didn't
have a lot of things they have not
Vickie's I bet personal trainers are you
kidding me no just anything we know I
know what you're saying
no we it was different back then
obviously just so many other just
distractions nowadays for players and
opportunities that just didn't present
themselves back then but I would be more
concerned with the Patriots decision to
not hang on to Jimmy Garoppolo a little
bit longer he looks like the real deal
doesn't he yeah look
I love what I'm seeing out of him and
just looking at them it is a first place
schedule next year a last place schedule
next year the longest road trip they
have the only time that they go to the
eastern time zone on the East Coast is
one trip to Tampa they face the Chargers
in Southern California
I'll do the solid by not even mentioning
the town there next year I think they've
got a chance with a top five pick and
the way he's playing maybe even make the
playoffs next year Dan oh yeah and you
look at Seattle situation and Arizona is
still a little bit in flux too so you
know the Rams and 49ers that would be
great to renew that great rivalry that
that they've had for so many years and
the Rams they definitely are the real
deal and the 49ers always seem to play
them well so you don't think there's
anything to do with Brady in the trainer
and the coach in New England Dan I hope
not
you know I I don't know but you know
it's one of those you trying to get
information to England as we all know
it's difficult to say the least right
Dan Fouts joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show when you played we knew what
a catch was pretty much and you know we
had Mike Pereira the former head of NFL
refs in studio saying that when he even
reffed
in 96 that what we saw at the end of the
Steelers Patriots game would have been
ruled a catch where do you stand on on
the 21st century catch rule with instant
replay involved in I stand confused each
week I'd get more confused there are
things you can do as a running back to
break the plane and then lose the ball
and it's a touchdown there are times
when you can go into the end zone as a
runner and only have one foot in the end
zone and it's a touchdown you can fly
over the pylon and lose control of the
ball and it's a touchdown so they really
have to take a real hard look at what's
going on and maybe just going back to
the judgement of the officials on the
field as it used to be and not leaving
it to guys in the studio who have you
know slow motion and all these type of
you know tools to work with let's get
back to the human element
the game and let it go with that I don't
think anybody would argue on either side
you know in that game with the Steelers
that that was a touchdown I just don't
understand why we can't you know players
make mistake coaches make mistakes
officials are going to make mistakes
it's a human game mistakes are bound to
happen but when you take the human
element out of it and put it in you know
the robots and then you get confusion so
what would you do I mean because as you
know CBS and Fox and ESPN and NBC have
some of the greatest technology in the
world we're showing it to Joe and Jane
six pack at home we should just not have
replay at all when it comes to the goal
line do you think Dan works your stance
on that no I think you you still need a
replay there obviously you have really
good uses for it I just think that when
there's a question as to catch no catch
you know let the officials on the field
have the last say you know we have the
officials going over looking at a you
know a pad at a tablet in really he's
got no decision all he's doing is is
making a you know a charade out of it
because it's the decision being made in
New York that will stand all right Dan I
have a good Christmas in in Houston I
know you're calling the game on Westwood
one and we'll see the Chargers and the
Jets this coming weekend and and tell
ayan we sent the same pretty can you
have me on we'll always den love our
chats that's Dan Fouts Pro Football Hall
of Famer the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience